the dave chappelle thing
is all over the news right now dave
chappelle kind of moved out of the way
homie homie is not looking good the guy
that ran up on him his face is on you
know
clearly
his arm is looking like
what would you do if someone ran up on
you and then part b to that is why do
you think
ice pick you're just gonna hit him with
it i got nice
just on you
you're gonna ice pick don't even [ __ ]
hesitate he just has the ice pick ready
why do people feel so comfortable
going up and talking to comedians
comedians should be
the truth tellers in society they're
supposed to offend everybody want to
hear no truth no more okay they want to
hear they want to they want you to
appease and stroke their egos and
man
this is i go going back to i don't tell
comics that they not they don't have it
right now i just tell them hey man and
it and i and i feel
horrible doing it too because i would
rather say man you need some work but i
just like man you was great man
just because that's what you want to
hear are you trying to hit him with the
jack nicholson thing like you can't
handle the truth
it's dead is that what people is that
what the reason that people are
attacking chappelle on stage or even the
will smith thing is it the truth hurts
is that where you're going with this
it's different from everybody it's not a
blanketed thing but the the point is
that comics are under attack for things
that they say
because you in a society where people
don't want to one hear the truth one
thing that there's no such thing as
truth like we live in a society right
now where opinion is right
like opinion is the facts yeah and you
and you asked somebody
opinion can never be
the facts
but they think
my opinion
is the fact so if that's the case if
your opinion is the facts what
does this people don't think their
opinion can be wrong
so if that's the case
how did somebody say this amen i had the
wrong opinion about you
how did that sentence happen then if
your sentence
and your opinion can't be wrong
and your opinions are the facts
man i've said so many things
that people have gotten upset about
because
they have an opinion about things they
have never thought about
you i
if you walked up to me and asked me
about
what's the coin those coins whatever
bitcoin
if you ask me about it
and i just immediately say man that [ __ ]
have you have you
have you ever heard about it no i'm just
saying there's some [ __ ] right like
but if you don't know something about it
how can you make
like where does all this information
come from if you don't if you've never
heard of it i had to research
bitcoin i bought some bitcoin i've never
made a dollar of like i made some money
then it was gone like the next day like
like
so
i was like you know something now
somebody asked me about bitcoin look at
some [ __ ] yeah you're basically saying
there's a difference between facts and
the stories you're telling yourselves we
literally did a whole class on this the
other day right tyler
and that facts are not the same as your
story what they say is that you know
facts don't care about your feelings
you're saying that everything is getting
blended right everything is getting
blended in today's society i i don't
think that i think differently than that
and that's the way i think but that's
not the facts
it does does alternative and natural
mean the same thing
no does artificial and natural mean the
same thing no
so if somebody say they have 100
natural juice can you say you have a 100
percent artificial juice
one juice is from the grape and one
juices some some grape drink like it's
not the same but you want me to believe
[Music]
and you want me to accept
artificial juice
as natural juice
and you want to manufacture that content
and it's because today because of social
media
anybody can make juice
yeah
anybody can make jesus without no type
of guidelines yup or gatekeeper
hey man
this is not approved by anybody
but
it works
how do you know it worked have you done
some research
i just know this [ __ ] work
post it on okay
did you try
where are the lab rats that you did
introduce
can you start a garden without knowing
where the sun hits
no you can't sir
it's the thing but but people hey just
put the garden box
right there does it get any sun i don't
know right but it will grow right
and and without there's probably people
that without even knowing this guy that
tackled dave chappelle defended him you
know what i mean like there's got to be
people on both sides well he the trans
community that that's that's who he's
offended the most so he's a transgender
guy i don't is no we don't know he was a
he was actually a huge mega guy trump
guy really this like tackle trump yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
gave him right that's what he said he
was yeah no he's he's got songs out
about trump he's a big trump big trump
guy i thought he was a guy i thought he
was a gothic dude because i saw his
nails was painted
too he was also wearing like a thrasher
looking
yeah so i thought he was let's find him
real quick or anything any information
on this oh that's his name yeah his name
is what isaiah isaiah lee
now um
ali what was what's your reaction that's
him right there that's him yeah no
that's him yeah that's the girlie that's
the guy that's the guy that's the guy he
looks so different wow he was beat up
all over the place darker he looks
darker skinned in the in the video he's
a kid he's a kid it oh no they're 21
years old
that's what he had it was a fake gun
with a knife with a knife on the edge
yeah so
how does he not get charged with assault
right oh he will they drop no they know
they're not charging them why because
it's [ __ ] california they don't
charge nobody for [ __ ] yeah i i don't
know if i i'm not charging him not
charging him for this and
i that the beating the beating and see
but see this is the thing that
i i
when the will smith thing happened i
tried my best not to comment on it
because i know everybody was giving a
take right and
i said that
will smith
has just okayed
all this emotional
bull crap that that that
young people and seem like older people
have started drifting into
that
i can just
wrap myself up on my feelings
and decide that i'm going to attack
somebody for what they said see at the
end of the day chris rock is still a
comic
and i was taking this upon so comics are
under attack for what they say
okay
are you offended by anything else that i
said to somebody else that may have been
offensive to somebody else
you only offended by
the anything that i say or any comic
says could be offensive to somebody of
course
so you taking the liberty to attack when
will smith did that at the oscars
i said wow
you just okayed it for every
young cat out here that's dealing with
his emotions that has a gun
or a knife
to say
this is what i can i can do this i can
attack for words
a lot of people
will
run into a situation where they will get
they will get hurt hurt
like this happened to me
2017.
the people who this is why and i tell
people this and they know this in
houston the people who ran up on me on
stage
filed assault on me
afterwards to get some money because but
they they ran up on you on stage yeah
physically tried to assault you
and then i assume you roughed them up
real good yeah and they filed an assault
charge on you that's like that reminds
me of people like you've heard these
stories like someone broke into
somebody's house and the person who shot
them who shot them or beat the [ __ ] out
of them
they got charged with
battery or assault or whatever weird
yeah with the with the gun laws like i
live in texas everybody can have a gun
if somebody jumps your gate
and they're in your backyard
you can't shoot them
in your backyard they have to be
getting in the house
so that's how the people get charged
like i
my daughter has a gun license and i say
somebody come to your house you you pop
out she's like daddy
that's not how it works and she want to
tell me the technical rules of it i
don't hear
but back to the will smith thing you
think that that opened the floodgates
for letting emotions get the best of you
and do what you want so this is just a
symptom of a bigger problem it's a
symptom of a bigger of a huge problem to
where
it's
it's sad because i know a lot of people
are going to get hurt because
it's people
like i'm not dressing up no more i i
wear things on stage that i can easily
yeah if you get tore up i don't even
care hold on
you're consciously making that decision
i'm rolling up in sweat suit sweatpants
like i'm feeling good well i wear
nice stuff but it's nothing that i'm no
rings no chains it's not like nothing so
you're saying but this is something
you've been doing for a while yeah so
you're saying i'm expecting some [ __ ] to
happen ever since what 2017. i've been
i've been wow if you like even with
steve brown when the dude attack steve
brown on stage
all this [ __ ] is emotional [ __ ] that
people
it's a speech is violent [ __ ]
[Music]
you